foreign
gamespot's weekly hangout every Tuesday
at 2PM Pacific right here on
gamespot.com I'm your host Danny Dwyer
joined by Chris Waters dude you're back
yeah what's up buddy I was back last
week you were back last week remember
that last time we did this show last
week it's called the blur God damn it
odor I gotta say we were saying that
summertime sometimes not the best time
to have a show you know he's scrambling
for stuff not this week we got the crew
we got the beta for the crew we're gonna
try and jump the border and uh that
Abe's Odyssey remakes out as well new
and tasty we're gonna play some of that
in a second Crypt of the network dancers
here and as you saw from all the amazing
dance moves from everyone here at
gamespot.com and we're gonna have some
fun with that later on uh plus girls
make games are in the house
let's try that again let's read it it's
a new machine we have so every time we I
put my hands in the air people scream
it's pretty impressive you tried it it
doesn't work with you
oh wait
can we turn it on so it works for Chris
it's like haptic feedback it's like it's
like it doesn't make it does it like can
we go
and this is why they don't let us have
an audience can we just do this for an
hour all right we better play some video
games uh before we do actually you're
off to Comic-Con in a couple of days
yeah yeah yeah like tomorrow literally
oh really preview night is Wednesday
down in San Diego and then Thursday
Friday Saturday from four to six uh
we've got a live show demos coming in
there we got Battlefield Hardline
recently delayed until 2014. oh you hear
the news yeah that just happened today
oh I didn't realize uh yep and uh gonna
have some Lego Batman 3 some evolve I
think some uh some Destiny which people
are gonna Taste of in the beta but maybe
it'll be something different there
Comic-Con sweet yeah shows are filling
up I'll be putting out a call for
questions for the live show uh at my
Twitter CT water so be sure to follow
that and uh yeah you see a bunch of
whole Comic-Con functions and a Prosser
coming gonna be uh shooting some
segments some cosplay stuff that's gonna
be good yeah it's fun that'll be good
I'm looking forward to watching it uh
bum not to be going this year yeah but
I'm going to get to go to Gamescom the
following week for like three weeks or
something I know yeah I gotta go home
see my family yeah it's been a while
that'll be good anyway for now let's
play some video games uh Abe's Odyssey I
have a feeling that this was a bigger
game in Europe than it was over here I
always did have that kind of you're that
that distant feel of like when I when it
came into my awareness in Massachusetts
I was like oh this game seems cool it
seems like it's got it was written about
or talked about with like a lot of
energy that I didn't really see among my
my peers I guess I don't know I had some
friends who were into it though everyone
back home uh at least in Ireland I know
it was popular in the UK as well I
actually think it was developed in the
UK I know the lead guy is British
um but everyone who had a original
PlayStation Lauren Lanning I had this
British did not struck me or maybe I'm
wrong I actually so I interviewed him at
E3 he was on our live stage and so this
is odd World new and tasty is the name
of this game but it's uh it's more than
an HD remake of Abe's Odyssey like
they've got they went back and got all
the assets from the original game they
still had them at a
odd odd people or whatever the dev's
name is uh and they the artists were
able to use those to just create all new
art to create all these new environments
this is straight up shot for shot almost
the intro to the original game the one
difference I've seen I've not played
this at all yet I played the original
one today and I've never completed it
it's actually like an incredibly
difficult game and Munch is Odyssey was
great as well but the main difference I
saw with this is that instead of the the
screens kind of going like Prince of
Persia style when you move to the left
it's a new screen shifts the whole card
in or something like that so it was like
each screen was a puzzle whereas now it
just seems like it actually Scrolls
along with you yeah and I'm actually
we're gonna knock out a graphics
comparison between this and the original
one on Game Spot so I'm gonna I'm gonna
skip this bad boy and hit her oh that
was Abe this is the exact same Soul
flight Abe he looks he's like this
hapless
uh goofball who's just trying to not get
killed basically this is motivation yeah
so this life is terrible this uh this
place uh is basically where they're
making these burgers and then he comes
to find out that they're actually making
the burgers out of the workers
so the modicans as they were known
that's the that's why that's called he's
a modican yeah the bodies are against
your basically robots
so the reason this game's weird because
it is a game that's based up on
platforming and half on dialogue
so you can go hi hello
follow me right there wait here
these are all totally different voices
to the original one as well well yeah
they've redid All the voices and they
actually got like part of their
Kickstarter I think was
a tear people could donate and do mood
again voices really yeah and they got
like Lauren said they got like famous
people wanting to do it who really like
really been big fans he did not name
drop however so I I can't name drop I
can only say Lauren Lanning a few more
times that's the only name I can drop
here say it again Lauren Lanning so the
other thing is that see the darkness
here yeah on the darkness look I'm hella
in the light and that guy in the
foreground can like turn around and she
choose and see you if you're not in the
shadow yeah back there so they uh I
don't know it's a it was a really clever
for like 2D Platformers which you know
have the opportunity to be super trite
if they want to uh Abe's Odyssey was a
was a really those are landmines by the
way they are red and pointy yeah which
denotes Danger
I can sneak past him
oh very graceful
I even remember this tutorial being
super freaky
eventually you can like actually take
control of those guys
I think I'm allowed to come down here
without waking him I'm not sure
yeah go go tiptoe over there
are you gonna go past it must be
terrified of these things that's because
they can just totally they have guns and
like for arms or something I think I'm
supposed to hit this do it
we're good yeah
sneak on by
yeah there's those guys and there's
these you've seen pictures of them a few
of them they've got like they're these
little tripod dudes with big scoop mouth
Spike things going on do you see the the
levers here oh God I totally killed that
dude that was brutal you see that
gruesome yeah that was so bad casualties
won or is that seven I think that's one
all right oh
man all right I guess
who knows you were made of birds the
whole time
oh back here
come on video games
so one of the things that was super
appealing about this game to me was the
animation style and the artwork I mean
it's it's full of like this this goofy
personality this sort of like non-trade
I mean you know this is a a grim
Factory's a grim Factory but like
Abe and other of his ilk that he
encounters that all the enemies that
look just super Sinister yeah it's that
weird thing it's like that Playstation
One era of we're trying to make a game
look really gritty but we've just
figured a 3D and no matter how we try
everything we make is kind of childlike
looking like it's like Grand Theft Auto
one I could I could have not kill them
why did you not I didn't do it again
switch is right there how am I supposed
to not touch well this is how you learn
that your actions have consequences
today all right this guy asleep please
be asleep I really don't want to have to
do this part again
yeah bro press the square
yeah it's like Grand Theft Auto one at
the same kind of uh thing as well I
think the birds are a checkpoint they
are a checkpoint
what why did you just fall on your body
do you know that Abe's Odyssey was the
first game to use birds as a checkpoint
I did not know that now in 2014 all
games use birds as checkpoints Birds
everywhere I think yeah in the crew like
your car gets crapped on by birds
checkpoint
all these guys just damn
yeah I can say I love these guys
yeah you're supposed to save them
I can say stay here or follow me
I can fart and stuff as well I forget
what those buttons are oh man this is
the exact same menu as the PlayStation
version
you can spell quick save without a c oh
if I hit a musical or two
I can fart d-pad let's see if for dinner
that's not a that's a mouth part okay I
wanna I wanna Bud part will you just
thank you
laughs
gets him every time never gets old
I think these the fact that we've sat
here for long seconds and giggled at
farts uh is a perfect segue to eminent
strangers question coming in over twitch
does this hold up today compared to
other downloadable games or is it a
mostly nostalgic experience uh so we
should say right off the bat this game
is thirty dollars
that seems like more than a game of its
ilk in this area yeah it's I don't know
like download the games oh those guys
have just disappeared uh yeah I guess
we're not used to spending that much
money especially for HD remakes
but uh yeah I don't know I like this is
super nostalgic Factor I'm not really
sure if a game of this like this uh
is like I don't know if it appeals to
people yeah well like we said we uh we
are just playing it for the first time
now it's out just today oh God before
did you say hello to him I did I said
hello and I think he just murdered no
talking didn't you see the sign
well at least he died for it yeah I got
him to stand on that thing hey what's up
you want to see me fart watch this right
in his face right in his face come on
oh
he just keeps on that's his life man he
just keeps on scrubbing away hey don't
come at me that's how resigned he is to
his fate of becoming a mudicon burger
leave Americans in the bird portals I'm
pretty sure if I walk he's gonna just
walk straight through that beam they're
not they're not that clever no so I'm
pretty sure he'll just die if I so what
I have to do is
just chill out for a sec man I gotta I
gotta say yo dude come here watch him
I'd stay here
what are you doing stay there
all right what's this guy doing
catching them Z's he's not standing on
the thing though you can throw uh bottle
caps
right that's a new thing you can throw
stuff what button I gotta wait for the
the happy message to scroll by again
throwing with an unlimited supply of
baller caps oh just just like the menu
oh [__] oh oh fair enough well that
works who needs ball caps
or you can roll on like that as well
it's pretty good no
now you can't save that guy okay well
you have you have to lead him to the
bird portal yeah I know because I'm
gonna turn that off is a bird portal
gonna come back yeah all the birds flew
away Daddy I'm very sure
I mean they might come back so what you
see in the old one is you'd leave the
area you were in
oh wait I totally messed that up sorry
all right oh I remember this okay okay
you out of this time I think I hold both
triggers there you go oh nicely done as
you're first saved the other guys you
just left I just left them there yeah
they just broke the bird portal and
pieced out yeah they are Burgers now I
feel pretty bad about things to you if
you have any more questions by all means
uh twitch chat Gamespot comments Chris
will read them out and the one thing I
want to do that I haven't done yet is
take over one of these guys his brains
you can like straight up you think you
can do that this early on you could yeah
pretty pretty early
sneak just to steam vents with L1 that
seems like it's gonna burn me
no I'm okay they can hear you moving
even if you're hidden
I don't see any of the sligs though
oh there's one just wait just wait there
it'll be fine everything's gonna be fine
hey everything was pretty fun I was just
lying to you there I don't know if it
was going to be fine this is so scary
this is still scaring
it's scaring me so badly is it
frightening you because you're worried
about your own fate or because little
Daniel Dwyer is in there inside of you
cowering and you're like just remember
fearing it yeah I think it's that I
think it's the same part of me that
laughs every time I fart on one of these
guys
all right go in the bird portal thing
no come here come here we're in range
can you get the other guy down there to
go on the same portal uh yeah I could
but whatever whatever oh yeah these
things are so scary what they're they
look like they might uh explode or
something yeah you gotta hit them on the
green though
foreign
was that helpful I think I'm supposed to
do it on the green so scary wait wait
before you go there go back to the other
mood again real quick because Alicia 128
wants to know yeah can you still slap
fools in this oh
let's see a slap
that cheese slap I can make Birds appear
out of nowhere that's even more made of
birds we've established this I don't
know yeah he's like I don't know what to
do either Abe
because I can do that one pretty good
how to prove it oh okay yeah you can
you're right I can't think about it I
don't know which ones it said slap so uh
verdicts the jury still had on that one
Alicia
oh that's so tense good job
what I gotta do next
uh jump
can I make that I don't think I can make
that sure
nope
he's dead I don't know Danny I just say
things to get you murdered
more birds are you gonna it's weird like
even the like length of the you dying
and checkpointing is like almost the
exact same
like a little too long yeah yeah exactly
like why is this all right just hold out
right run a joke there you go
Abe's not a standing broad jump kind of
guy
he needs a running leap
mitsa oh Pizza I think this is how it
works works there you go whoa all right
so now I'm this dude and I'm not sure if
I can fart as him but let's try
you're just hassling that yeah you can
like
straight up shoot I'm gonna shoot this
dude you just blew something up I think
oh my goodness oh I'm sorry he's drunk
with power
yeah so you know that's kind of the the
the
I don't know the short and easy on just
run into the pit so this part here
legitimately used to take me forever to
try and be well you're gonna you're
gonna try it after you run this guy into
this I can't because he can't jump you
can only shoot he can't just walk off
the ledge I can walk off the ledge
there you go there you go there you go
now you're Abe and you can try to jump
through that part and then we can all
Mock You hey
just raising my hands up but someone is
on point over there what do you think
about our world new and tasty
so this on PS4 it's coming soon to PS3
and Vita and it's crossed by cross Save
which takes a little bit of this thing
off of the of the price tag 29.99 but
yeah and then it's also going to be
coming to PC and then later this year
Wii U and Xbox One okay that's the word
there you go there it is everything get
your odd World new and tasty uh if you
although if you don't want to play that
game if I don't play Sniper Elite V3 for
instance it's just again pull on out
we're giving away a bunch of codes uh
we're gonna Revenge codes for other
stuff as well I believe I'm gonna have
to get skivvy on that but if you want
one of those Sniper Elite codes and DLC
and DLC as well hunt for the gray wolf
DLC oh yeah I have the computer right
here nice work uh we're giving away
codes for uh hashtag GS the lobby make
sure you're following us on Twitter so
we can DM you your code if you win and
yeah we got a bunch of those uh PS4
codes so if you want one of those bad
boys make sure you tweet us soon during
the show at least uh we're gonna be back
soon we got the crew beta Thai Roots
gonna come on we're gonna try and jump
border but in the meantime we got some
sort of uh
Comic-Con update Shenanigans Comic-Con I
believe it's a video that I myself
caught
couldn't even remember that stay back
we're back in a second with the crew
thank you
all right
welcome back to the lobby folks the crew
ubisoft's driving extraordinary games at
November 11th I'm delighted to be joined
by Mr Ty root hi Danny what's up Ty
what's up man yesterday we went on a
little bit of a road trip we did we went
uh we went to our home we went to San
Francisco we did we drove from Detroit
Detroit the whole way to San Francisco
yeah it took maybe an hour and it took a
long time about an hour let's say so
we're currently in San Francisco in the
crew and we could actually show the game
like in terms of the types of races you
do activities I forgot you put us in
this weird part yeah so we're currently
stuck behind a wall in Sausalito
so that's a safe place to lose your
vehicle we should get out of here so
we're gonna try and just I don't know
the scale of the crew is what I'm
finding the most interesting so let's
just try and drive south and hit the
Mexican border I'm not sure if we can do
it in 15 minutes I'm also really sorry I
put you Behind These Walls yeah you did
how do I get out of here I think just
that I'm just gonna keep going I said so
I know the Golden Gate Bridge is right
over there yeah so we're gonna make our
way down through I guess I think ready
ready
oh another car all right cool so when we
when we did this it was squirrely we
drove through Chicago we drove through
Salt Lake City we should we should do a
waypoint right now yeah just so we can
see where we're going here yeah so look
at the look what we did yesterday it
took about an hour and yeah so we went
from 15 minutes from here Detroit all
the way to the West Coast
in the beta yeah super impressed that
you can do that so we should just go to
La okay the Border well that's well
that's on our way I mean yes the
Waypoint for the quarter I mean you're
gonna end up in L.A right there ain't no
Baja Peninsula so we can't fudge it
a few weeks ago is there a Tijuana down
there no I don't think so yeah I mean
that's it's that border town right there
whatever okay so oh there we go there's
one across maybe right there boom okay
cool all right awesome Tick Tock yo boom
you're gonna drive down the one oh no
here we go okay I believe I can do this
so the one thing I I realized we should
probably do when we get to La is tune
the car for street because I've realized
now that the reason why this thing has
no control whatsoever is because we
forgot the tuna when we left yeah it was
really hard you're driving through the
freeways of salt like with uh with a
Mustang which does not really want to
turn
this thing sucks with control but the
accuracy was pretty cool what was we saw
a bunch of stuff in San Francisco at the
ferry building was there yeah absolutely
noon Square
Fisherman's Wharf yeah the marina
I mean we even had pop collar douchebags
in the marina
Golden Gate Park does not exist in
here's the marina we're here right now
yeah but we're not because we just came
out we're driving down to 19. so this is
like this what is this like the sunset
now I guess but it says it's the marina
it says the stuff yeah so what that road
just said
just like San Francisco there's just too
many freaking cars on the road it must
be Market Street right maybe no we drove
down I think markets disconnected it's
going to show us it says pack Heights so
I don't really understand how that could
be but what I'm gonna get us there we'll
keep going I believe in you uh so this
is the crew this is a I guess like I
don't know cross between Burnout
Paradise Test Drive Unlimited it has a
lot of like both those yeah I guess when
they I guess the guys that eaten the
test Drive Unlimited on the 360 all got
together and just started their own
Studio this Ivory Tower Tower which is
weird because that's kind of like a like
a negative connotation here you know
it's like get off your Ivory Tower bro
especially for a bunch of guys who have
like actually but it's like a bunch of
what academically that know what's best
right for the rest of the world so when
it comes to driving games maybe they
know what's up well they have a great
pedigree they do the best Guys and Dolls
in the actual entire like driving game
franchise like when you think about the
games that were really good open world
driving games you're thinking about
Burnout Paradise Test Drive Unlimited
yeah and they were kind of these weird
temples where you'd never actually had a
sort of a big game in between yeah like
there's not many games that are really
try like Need for Speed kind of flirted
with it a little bit didn't really pull
it off uh whereas I feel like like sorry
dude it's like a long time
well the cool thing was is like they
honestly that's Pacifica this is like
this is the one this is PCH Pacific
Coast Highway we're cruising beautiful
it's pretty it is it's a fun game I've
been having a blast with it um I I like
I was a big fan of Test Drive Unlimited
so this is kind of like that spiritual
successor to the game it's it's cool so
you've played a bunch of the actual you
know game not just driving around like a
campaign or stuff yeah well the story
seems to be I don't know from talking to
Kevin the story it does not seem like
it's well you know what it's not that
it's bad it's just very like it's that
very standard Hollywood Trope right
brother got shot you killed my brother
yeah and then I was incarcerated and I
had five years to dwell on the fact that
hey I'm gonna get revenge on this
[__] one day and dream about driving
cars exactly
so it has it has that Catalyst right
that it needs to kind of just push the
story forward but it's not like it's a
great story Jessica nearly drove into
the wall there yeah so who are all these
clearly not someone's gamer tag people
that you're passing yeah they're all
have like nice first names which no one
on the internet ever does no so we
passed Jessica there we had uh Isaac in
Salt Lake City
um I'm not sure I think they're meant to
be player characters but something about
like the way she was driving there it
seemed like it was not a player see
there's okay
they're also nice
so Madison Madison here is like just
yeah let's hang out and party I feel
like do a crew Drive what if it's like
the dev team they're just like okay yeah
right yeah wow just maybe they're just
using their names regular names I don't
know they're um I like that you can do
like the flags like you know where
they're from at least if that's true
there's that one guy from Ireland
yesterday there was yeah what do you
mean by Flags like when there's a little
icon show up uh was that a lady from
Russia yeah it just comes up in India
it's great
what do you think of this bendy Ghost
GPS line I love this thing I'm already
into it this is great yeah because you
can see how it curves ahead of time so
you kind of know where you're supposed
to be going you know how the road's
going to react you have a Wibble wobble
yeah
well the anime made a good point
yesterday about like in driving games
whenever you see that stuff on the
ground sometimes you think it's your
racing line
and you're just kind of cling to it and
what I liked about this is when we were
going uphill when you're going uphill
you can't really see where the line is
once it goes over a crest of a hill
whereas on this case because it's always
getting you always knew what direction
we've been driving for like five minutes
here right check the map okay
because like I think over almost gonna
hit LA right like so we are close to Big
we're not we're barely halfway to La
yeah so there's Big Sur
what's Big Sur that's like it just
beautiful
it is they straight up have Laguna
secular yeah oh yeah
[__] I'm sorry Big Sur is this whole
beautiful region down the coastline
that's full of wonderful nature
situations nature situations yeah that's
it that's what we call them yes that's
what the travel industry calls
absolutely I love that the game's kind
of has the objective of go to Junior
Street we've got three nature situations
the best nature situations in the west
let's just see like that's the word oh
man wow
you're part of my crew Waters yep I'm
not going to damage you you're a married
man you're safe here you have a wife
that would come after me if anything bad
that's true and she knows how to use
power so I would not screw with you at
all or in danger your life same with you
Danny uh so look at this I'm I'm just
saying hey you know what it's cool I'm
gonna pass you I better have a password
I'm just gonna pass you on this blind
curve yeah but no problem that's how I
roll this is this is this there's
another see like I get I don't know who
these people are I'm at Jordan Jordan
yeah
um is that Michael Jordan uh so one of
the developers tweeted me just before
they came online
um and said wow maybe we should be like
we should check out the LA Convention
Center oh really yes all right that's a
good goal he's one of the environment
artists oh I don't drive a cockpit a lot
hey Trey's watching now you might even
be in the chat you guys getting sick I'm
kind of getting sick uh Danny are we
giving people uh beta codes for this
game no sorry those were for uh snipers
oh my best snipers I don't know what the
deal is with the beta so I I think it's
an open sign up right uh I believe so
yeah but it's go online but it's only
for PC right now only PC I'm the worst
through Uplay and there was just so
awesome
and you said there was like sign up
problems this morning you couldn't even
log in this morning yeah it was all but
they fixed it it's good now there have
been a few spots a few of these turns a
few of these little uh sort of General
Store outposts that you've passed that
have looked uncannily like actual
locations I've passed yeah yeah
California they've done a good job yeah
when we went through Salt Lake City
um Andy was like pointing at the
Tabernacle oh cruise ship sorry stuff
like that was incredibly and he said he
said the um it's the big Mormon temple
or whatever it is the most accurate one
it was more accurate than the one than
the last of us oh really yeah
Beach
uh okay couple of questions here Bob
Jones 1980 what is the install slash
download size do you remember I think it
was like 14 gigs it was like 15
gigabytes okay yeah at least on PC and
it took all night to download and do the
cars take visible damage yes what are
those buildings yes
we're going this way though oh my God a
condor I might be wrong but I think
those buildings are actually on that
drive down to yeah yeah
those are like big Square buildings on a
hill on the way down to Santa Cruz look
at that guy he's squirrely well I would
have thought we'd be past Santa Cruz by
now yeah we are maybe we're past Santa
Cruz we're like at whatever that point
is what's it called Point conception
something like that is that really about
gold no it is whatever divides uh
Southern California and Northern where
you have your babies so there's like
boats and or it's something like that
I'm totally wrong I'm sure but you said
they take the homage but you don't have
to like you don't have to like fix up
your car and like that view no I haven't
it when it responds and it's just
perfect again so is it cosmetic damage
or is it like uh you messed up your axle
real bad yeah so it doesn't have a good
time driving it's more Arcadia in the
sense it's just like yeah it's all
cosmetic I don't think it affects your
car it may but I haven't noticed it at
code seven uh why why truck code seven
on games
I have not so the weird thing is I like
saw a bunch of cops that had like a
roadblock it wasn't for me but it was
just like whatever yeah it was there and
I ran through their roadblock hit a car
and they just nothing happened we should
make the point as well that we are
playing this while still in the tutorial
yes the game wants us to go to tuner
Street which is in Detroit we're
supposed to tune our car so yeah so
everything that's happening here you
couldn't even be bothered to finish the
tutorial before you just lit out for the
coach we wanted to go to uh San
Francisco yeah we saw Vegas and
everything we did we saw it was great
and we went to the mountains that was
pretty the game is actually on PC it's
not it looks good I like it
um
it again like what was Test Drive
Unlimited it wasn't like in Hawaii or
something like that yes and I was in
Hawaii
yeah right yeah this is it's good though
where are we now is this Santa Cruz uh
no we are this is getting closer okay I
was gonna stop and look at the map
that's fine let's keep going this looks
very Southern California to me yeah this
is this this kind of beef this is like
Santa Barbara Santa Barbara oh Santa
Barbara cool there's some good college
girls here yeah worst yeah you can't run
over people the UCSB is a fine academic
institution
every city
at this stage uh UC UC sorry yeah
there's a UC everywhere so it's Aaron
Aaron's in front of us it's uh hey Aaron
uh don't you like crazy
it's driver uh style so you can't run
over people they tend to like they died
they're all like yeah so you're like
writing you're approaching Malibu now
which is just North of L.A oh got some
got some air it's where there's there's
like five feet of land between the
highway and the ocean and people build
their houses on really yeah and they're
all gonna tumble into the seat look at
that Lighthouse yeah hey let's look at
it hi Lighthouse don't crash sorry it's
fine
I like that I like how easy it is to
look behind you and stuff it's that's
great to admire the sights just so you
know I love the scale of this game is
that John Major is in my ear right now
saying that we have two minutes left
yet we haven't done anything we haven't
even made it to Los Angeles we're gonna
keep going we gotta we gotta see we
gotta go oh my god oh crap oh there you
go
there's your damage damage isn't it's
not two if I hit him head on you see
like a giant dent in the car now the
cool thing is like I like the
customization there's awesome options
when you get to like those like those
tune shops so right now what we would
want to do is tune our car for Street
and then you get like nitrous and you
can mess with the hood and put a spoiler
on your car change the color because we
went off-road in Vegas and my car was
not happy with it yeah it doesn't work
really well so and you can see like that
little thing up there saying please go
to tuner shop please go to Tunisia oh
it's getting squirrely oh God I love it
I can go to the beach
we're almost there it did take us like
an hour and 15. another cruise ship
there's cruise ship to uh get to San
Francisco I think we're in L.A I think
we're approaching LA right now yeah
there you can see some of the skyline is
this the San Fernando Valley let's see
if you can find the convention center
without going to the map okay oh my God
you got one shot thank you for the
pressure appreciate it yeah man we're
gonna have to look at the map oh my God
it's like LA traffic there's cars
everywhere there's cars everywhere oh no
oh my God it's Maniacs driving in the
oncoming traffic lane okay all right
there's no way I got it okay Malibu
right I don't know okay it has to be
Santa Monica or something like that yeah
yeah isn't that so
oh this this has to be Santa Monica yeah
yep Santa Monica Los Angeles okay so now
we need to go east
and get somehow I think the route that
we have takes us I'm gonna go here yeah
I'm gonna go up here uh L.A and then try
to get or maybe I should have gone down
there crap oh God you totally murdered
person
and I just need to get to the freeway I
believe where's I-10 where's the Santa
Monica freeway
I'm going east right now oh screw this
he's going off the GPS oh my God I think
maybe he's going off the road
I know
I think you're still a little far north
yeah I go I go south I'm gonna go sit
like immediately I know it's the wrong
way I'm gonna I'm gonna do the freeway
we have to get on the freeway we have to
I don't know you might be okay because I
think you might have met back up with
the tunnel yeah see now we're in West LA
yeah
I take it back I did not need that map
at all
no no it's down it's down here oh is it
that's downtown or is that Century City
which one is we're going to E3 we're
going to E3 right now okay what's
happening we just came back from E3 are
you sure you want to go back oh my God
what's happened oh crap
come on come on come on come on
downtown's right ahead of us there we go
yeah look see there's the JW Marriott
and the Ritz Carlton it's right there
we're gonna see we're gonna be we're
gonna find it we're gonna find the club
I want to apologize to anyone who is
just standing by waiting to come on the
show in the next minute literally
standing okay now we've seen an exit the
freeway exit oh my God there's cars
everywhere and just like La freeways
there's no exits you can take when you
want to go somewhere so this is great
and people just park and people are just
like yeah we're just gonna block your
ass here I'm just gonna post up okay
hold on is that an exit please
go straight no no no get out there get
out there yeah it's fine
here we go exit okay hold on
so if I take a right here
oh wow this is preposterous do some
drifting all right cool thanks are you
thinking he's somewhere right is that it
no we have to get so you gotta get over
by the tall building is this [__] right
here can I go down here is that downtown
that's still downtown it might be too
because that's downtown oh God I'm gonna
hit a car crap okay hold on you need to
be south of downtown right
okay
is that her baskets yeah that is yeah
look there's you have ESP in the zone
we're in LA Live now hold on let's just
take a right yeah la Live's right it's
all on the right that is LA Live for all
those terrible restaurants I want to see
what the is it called the LA Convention
awesome that's amazing they've got an E3
billboard yeah crew right over the West
Hall okay that's awesome
we made it I'm happy that's great yeah
that's fantastic I want to see more of
that yeah let's get it that is the E3
sign that is the big one the E3 at the
Expo nicely done game designer yeah fair
play all right thank you so much Ty and
thanks for getting this to uh to E3
again hey much appreciated you know it
hasn't been that long I want to go back
but I love that that like genuinely took
a good like 20 like 15 20 minutes I mean
I think that's what people will do when
they play this game they'll probably
just want to like go visit their
Hometown whatever but you should
definitely spec out your car yes first
yes don't just buy Street Mustang and
then immediately skip the tutorial I'm
talking to Los Angeles because the worst
part is we have to drive the whole way
back to Detroit to keep another game no
you there's other there's other you
could probably find another tune there's
tune centers like in LA in Miami right
they're all locked oh they might be
locked away that's true sorry to Dan
mahore like whose account we've been
using he is now has to drive for 90
minutes to get back to Detroit yeah well
the crew it's added
what about games that are out right now
or at least within days of this exact
moment in time if you're watching this
live and not on demand in the future by
which point these games will be coming
out if only we had someone who was so
knowledgeable about all that so in tune
with new releases of video games to
purchase and play but the thing is we we
keep pretending that because Mary does
such a great job of it that she does all
on her own yeah she has like an army of
people she does to help her especially
today I've heard what's going on Mary
oh my God you guys
you can only know that when I work on
new releases it actually takes a whole
team of interns to help me
I actually don't know how to write so I
have all these girls helping me no I'm
kidding this is girls make games this is
a sweet sweet type this is like a camp
and a set of workshops where girls are
inspired to learn how to develop so
these are like the future developers
well they well that's the thing it's
like our job is to sit here on this
really comfy couch and just play games
and talk about them they're actually
going to go to the easy Danny the much
more difficult thing so easy to talk
about games trying to make the game you
girls are coders they're learning how to
program and it's just awesome and you
know what else they did this summer they
spent their summer working on a game
that they made in unity and they even
they got uh they was judged by Tim shady
and Kelly Santiago I mean that is so
cool so this is what they've been doing
all summer like learning how to code and
figure out game design and I think it's
really cool I have a few questions for
you girls what was it like to meet Tim
Schaefer
oh it was so cool he's such an
inspiration to us so it was really
incredible to meet him
I would expect nothing less from the
great Tim Schafer another question I
have for you guys is I've heard I
believe your team is called the
negatives does anyone have a sweet
explanation to why you'd be called the
negatives
ah
so our first day at camp we sat down
sort of and we were discussing team
names and our names were
negative apparently according to our
counselor and uh negative and we decided
to embrace our negative nature and to
become the negatives but we have a
positive number of people so technically
we're positive
wait okay so how what was if negatives
was like the the like most positive
negative name what was the most negative
negative name like is it safe I didn't
think of that was like video games suck
one of them or
well it started out with all the other
teams are terrible
shots fired well played shots fired
my last question for you guys is I heard
this winning game is called the whole
story can someone tell me about what the
whole story is all about
all right so in the whole story we
basically have a girl named Wendy and
she's digging in her backyard and she
finds a time capsule and she ends up
into the past and the only way for her
to get back is to try to help find a
missing princess
oh the old missing princess that's
awesome me unicorns me unicorns yeah so
oh there's a unicorn
so our main game mechanic is digging and
the unicorns actually give you riddles
so you dig to find the items are asking
for in The Riddles excellent when are we
gonna see it when we get to play it on
the lobby
um well you should check our check out
our Kickstarter and um you can get more
information there what's the address of
the kickstarter pimp your Kickstarter I
believe it
starter.com and it's girls make games
Grand Prize winner yeah yeah just look
up girls make games that's the whole
story how recent is that screenshot Mary
this is recent I found this all right
they're almost there
let's put let's push this bad boy over
ten thousand today yeah let's do it so
awesome guys so thank you so much and
now they're gonna help me talk about
some video games with some video games
that suck in comparison to their video
game
it's a shame that your game is not
coming out this week because that is
what new release is all about so let's
go check out the new releases that are
on today let's roll that footage the
first game we have coming out that I'm
going to talk to you about is the Dark
Souls 2 DLC crown of the sunken King are
there unicorns in this one there are no
unicorns forget it not interested can
you dig holes you can I don't know maybe
you can dig your own grave oh
sorry I got done next it got dark uh and
so that's coming out on July the 22nd
the first of three DLCs if you're
interested another that's coming out
which we just played what'd you guys
think of this game did anybody like it
no they did not like it
it sucks I heard a lot of Giggles from
the farts
I heard someone whisper it would have
been better if you could dig yeah it is
true if only you could dig in it needs
more unicorns
about all video games that's true
actually uh this is an interesting one
Gods will be watching which got a lot of
attention the last few months and now
you're it is out and it's based on moral
decisions it's a dark game about testing
you know the ethics of the questions
should you should you give up really
important information or will you let
your buddy lose an arm oh God it's
devastating is that is that is that
appropriate for for people on stuff
right now it is not appropriate close
your eyes girls The Walking Dead this is
the latest one episode four amid the
ruins I can't talk to you about it why
are you moving on to Wii U Sports Club
we use Sports Club is the latest for Wii
U it is exactly what you remember
playing with your grandparents but this
time it's in HD if you guys care and
there's different Club passes that come
with us
no they don't I was just told that they
do not come with Asana or tanning foods
that is made up by the marketing team so
if you guys like Wii sports that's
coming out this week as well did you
guys like any of those James
they all suck didn't they
they had to play one that's all the
games back to you Danny all my negatives
I want to say bye negatives bye we'll
get them back on later uh I want to see
if my if our life if our shouting
machine is still working
oh man uh we're gonna be back in just a
moment uh with some Crypt of the necro
dancer we gotta go set up our DDR pass
to play a role-playing game yes sure
dungeon crawling with dance let's see
how good that works uh slybrugmato and
our good friends uh from ongamers we're
at ti4 uh we trapped up yesterday all of
the money's gone to China uh but they've
produced a little feature for us uh so
uh let's check out and see for those of
you who missed the international uh what
was going on there over the weekend
thank you
khakis
hi guys cyborg Matt here at the
international 2014 main event at
Seattle's Key Arena as you can see
behind me they're just packing up we've
just had the grand finals and Ruby have
come out as the Champions they've won
five million dollars and they're
actually the highest earners in Esports
right now across old titles beating EG's
dejong in stock up two who's up there
I'm half a million so there's a big gap
there in terms of the main event we've
seen a whole bunch of people here over
10 000 people have turned up here at the
Seattle's Key Arena to watch all these
teams in action we saw eight teams
Advance the main event and that was five
Chinese teams two European teams and one
North American team the North American
team was of course steel Geniuses they
almost made it but they got knocked out
at last stage to Vichy gaming and
finished third place where they actually
netted themselves a million dollars and
BG gaming obviously for those who
watched today we're unable to beat
newbie it was a score of three to one
and won the first game very convincingly
but newbie came back and proved why they
are the best in the world BG gaming
walks away with 1.4 million dollars and
again it puts them right up there in the
top 10 owners in terms of all the
Esports titles and it's been crazy uh
we've been here since the 7th of July
where we had the playoffs and if you
remember before in Bellevue in the
western all the players moved over here
to Seattle and they've just give it all
the best in the main event and we've
seen the Chinese teams dominate here so
it's definitely uh Eastern Eastern
domination right now in terms of the
doctor two scene none of the Chinese
teams were eliminated by a European or
North American team they only eliminated
each other and as you can see newbie
come out on top and of course there's
plenty of content on ongames.com and on
our YouTube channel which we've
interviewed and we just did an interview
with how it was from Newbie one of the
winners and he was speechless pretty
much he didn't he doesn't even know what
to do next he wanted to grab lunch but
he doesn't even know what to grab thanks
guys
well here we are with Nick Road dancer
okay let's get right to it now I
pre-loaded some songs from our audio
Network it's where we do all of our uh
Library database for all of our videos
they're a real classy real original yeah
and they're fun okay so and they won't
get a suit like all the other songs
that's exactly right okay yeah those
songs be prepared are no good yeah
so this is a crypt of the necrodancer
which is a uh I guess Rhythm dance
role-playing adventure game
yeah this is it oh can't go that way
so you're tapping left and right that's
right for the skeleton and whenever
there's a uh enemy it breaks out into a
hot dance disco fever Vibe look at this
oh behind the leg coin multiply can we
get a shot of Rob's feet here
yeah look at that
oh can't go that way
oh you are cute you're a cute guy aren't
you
you're just going with the left foot
yeah there we go you're all confused if
you dig through that uh Rock one you
can't you can't crisp you can't do that
just can't happen nope there's looks
like there's some bombs there you can
pick up Rocks Don't Dance
just dirt oh here we go is this
Bomberman as well
uh let's see what happens how do I use
this bomb I forget
oh down left are you ready for this
explain to me why this is uh
let's get out oh God hmm explain to me
is this just a method of walking around
the game or is there like is it making
you play differently
well why not just use a keyboard it's
timing so if you script the timing
it's attacked as well see that's you
don't want to do that I'm glad I showed
you not to do that but you died
well
let's
try that again is this easier or more
less difficult I accidentally picked the
same leather fine
procedural right
all right we'll just get right out of
that
is this uh more or less easy to use than
connect
um this is very difficult
all right okay so here's here's a little
Lobby Zone let's try out uh
all those zones are on actually you know
what this is not great so unfortunately
I thought we were a little ahead here in
this safe but we're not so we're gonna
do that again here we go but yeah it is
procedurally I mean this is a different
layout than we saw last time
hmm I've got a question from alicia128
if you have any questions for uh
Funkmaster Handlery I'll by all means
put them in the Game Spot uh comments of
a glass shovel that doesn't seem like a
good weapon to use
alicia128 asks where's the twerking
where's the twerking Rob
uh the twerking uh comes in zone two
that was the song I chose lots of
twerking okay unfortunately you're gonna
have to find that out on your own
oh yeah baby
how much of this to be fixed
uh I played about uh 16 hours last night
another time this morning sounds
exhausting you must be very fit he was
like 15 pounds heavier before right Rob
the shopkeeper right now
kind of bump are you twerking against
the shopkeeper oh I was you were it is
true you can twerk
oh my God I can't take any of those
things get out of there you guys want to
try this
okay yeah
that's it for myself oh God
the temple sped up what do I do now Rob
so yeah attack
let's get in their Direction that's
right
you're doing it
up to the left and to the right and down
he's so much
I just showing you how to improve over
time Rob we're not allowed to because
we're streaming this on the internet oh
gosh we'd be sued but uh are you able to
uh use your own music in this as well
yeah that's that's the whole thing
so
I was actually listening to it and the
songs I had last night um they have to
be really Dancy and and
how do you say
um a systematic beat you can't just
throw in a rock song okay uh it has to
be a pretty consistent well that's what
you'd want I mean unless you really know
this rock song probably maybe it's
possible oh I I don't know what the Moon
I've got this
let him learn stay spend diamonds lose
leave lose diamonds
um the decisions leave
that's it right
so but if you do like
oh there it is he's killing monkey
oh back
oh
well I've terrible myself so why don't
we tag back here drag back in
got it I'm sorry
you can probably do some more dances out
here right I feel like
the more the merrier
be like oh yeah oh you see that yeah
that's on my laptop
all right we got to give out the winners
we're gonna end the show right here
folks we gotta give out the winners
for our sweet Sniper Elite V3 codes it's
a line dance
winners ask Jeff sxsw ask give it so ask
that Blind Bandit ask Jackson too like a
line dance come on come on
suicideforce at code seven at jordancos2
thank you so much everyone for getting
involved in our competition today
we're just going to spend the rest of
the night dancing I think hey Rob pop a
Beat
now you're getting it kids I wonder if I
put my hands in the air would it still
work
nope
thanks very much for watching the lobby
this week
okayspot.com
see you next time
oh oh now we do it
thank you